Dakota, do you still respect people without discipline?
Interesting. Okay. So first of all,
my baseline as a person is to respect people. That's my baseline. Now,
that is not the same as something we've talked now about before,
which is that doesn't mean I expect a lot from them. Okay?
You see the big difference there? I respect people. Hey, I respect you,
Spec what you're doing.
That doesn't mean I expect that you're going to be humble or you're going to be
hardworking or you're going to be brave,
or you're going to even be a slightly diff, decent human being.
I don't expect any of that, but yeah,
but I w and let me, let me phrase this carefully.
That doesn't mean I don't treat them with respect.
Now you notice I just changed this. Yes.
It's not just about I actually respect you. It's,
I'm going to treat you with respect. There's a big difference, right?
I'm going to, I'm going to treat everyone with respect.
But as far as actually respecting someone,
um, no, no, I'm not just automatically respecting people.
Now I'll treat them with respect because I don't know who they are.
I don't know what struggles they've had in their life.
I don't know what they've been through. I don't know that.
So I'm going to treat him with respect.
And it's very similar to Jujitsu perspective. You don't know. Okay.
Do you do to perspective Nogi, right? You don't know how good someone is.
You don't. You don't. And this is another thing, when do you,
when do you know how good someone is? And let's say you're better than them.
If you really understand Jujitsu,
you realize that you're better than them because you've been training longer.
Yeah, fundamentally. Right? Of course.
Are there some people that are just amazing athletes? Sure, sure.
But 98% of the people, you've just been training longer than them,
or you just were born a lot bigger than them or a lot stronger than them.
But you look at them and say, you know what, if this person, hey,
if we flip this around and this person been training longer,
I'd be the one getting crushed. Right?
So there's that now. So, so yes,
I treat people with respect and my, my attitude is generally to say,
look, I don't know what they've been through so I'm going to,
I'm going to treat him that way. Now that being said,
when someone just throws away their potential because they lack discipline,
that kind of bothers me. I mean, it doesn't mean that I don't respect them,
but I am definitely disappointed.
And in conditions where there is a gross lack of discipline,
just a gross lack of discipline,
I do move beyond just mere disappointment and I do get into the realm of,
I do not respect that person because they lacked discipline. So
there you go.
So it's like a respect meter kind of thing and you're starting at the base line.
Yeah. Yeah. I always start with everyone with respect.
You're to treat everyone with respect. And if you don't,
you don't know who you're disrespecting. Right? Who are you disrespect? I mean,
you could be disrespecting, first of all,
you could be disrespecting someone that is been through a lot that maybe you
should learn from. You could be, you know,
you're walking down the street and you disrespect.
You could disrespect someone that's a psychopath with a gun. Yeah.
And now you're in a shootout with them. People are getting, you know, I mean,
you're probably gonna win if you train hard, but still ugly innocence might be,
you know, by standards, you know, just don't know here.
You just know who people are. Yeah.
That's a good lesson to learn from his Jitsu man.
You don't know how good people are. You don't know,
not just how well they train,
but what are they been through that day in their life. You know,
you meet some people in the wrong day and there could be really a real problem.
Yeah.